I think by signing up with the Harry
Walker agency it's a clear indication
that we are going to see more of the
royal couple you know they suddenly want
to launch themselves in LA with a bit of
a bang and you know it will possibly
mean a little less time at home with
Archie I was told one of the things that
they most loved about lock down is being
together as a family they spend Father's
Day just the three of them you know they
really do love that family time and they
have a lot of that recently and I think
they both feel very grateful for that
time that they've had at home with
Archie watching him achieve all of those
milestones there's a hell of a lot of
concepts that up that are happening at
the same time and being able to have
family time we've got to celebrate those
moments where you just are on the floor
rolling around in hysterics because of
something that's happened and then these
inevitable deep off an hour later maybe
a day later there's going to be
something that you have to deal with and
there's no way that you can run away
[Applause]
[Music]
I think he is just about walking and
he's a very happy little boy he's loving
life in LA and they are still staying at
Tyler Perry's car rental they haven't
found their forever home yet they're
still looking and one of the things
that's really important to them is that
they finally somewhere a bit outside of
the Hollywood fray and with plenty of
space and plenty of critici-- for Archie
that's really key for them I understand
that Harry did speak to his father on
Father's Day
he speaks regularly with with his family
particularly his grandmother the Queen
and his father the Prince of Wales and
Harry would never let a day as important
as Father's Day go without picking up
the phone to to his father as far as the
royal brothers are concerned it's a case
of fait they are speaking and they speak
relatively readily they're not on the
phone to each other all the time they're
living different lives now I think the
time difference doesn't make things
particularly easy and but they are
absolutely on the talking terms and I
think they are making a point and an
effort and to connect particularly at
this time postcode and when they're
thousands of miles apart from each other
[Music]